OUTSTANDING COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
CONCERNS.
>> Bret: MORE ON THIS BUT THE
PANEL.
THANK YOU.
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
SAYS THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WILL NOT TOLERATE RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IN THIS FALL'S
ELECTIONS.
POMPEO MADE THE PROMISE TWO
CONGRESSIONAL HEARING TODAY.
HE DID NOT SAY WHAT THE
PRESIDENT MIGHT DO ABOUT IT.
HIS TESTIMONY WAS INTERRUPTED
BRIEFLY TODAY OVER A TOTALLY
UNRELATED MATTER.
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON HAS THE
STORY FROM THE STATE DEPARTMENT
TONIGHT.
>> SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO WAS THERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET.
THIS HEARING GOT TESTY OVER
ANOTHER ISSUE.
HIS QUESTIONING OF
HILLARY CLINTON DURING A 2015
BENGHAZI HEARING WHEN HE WAS
STILL A MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
>> I TAKE DIPLOMATIC SECURITY
VERY SERIOUSLY.
NEVER MAKE AN ACCUSATION.
>> IF I COULD JUST EXPLAIN --
OKAY.
WE WILL GIVE YOU TIME BUT WE
WANT THE SECRETARY TO RESPOND.
>> HE DID NOT DO THAT WITH
SECRETARY CLINTON.
>> TESTIFYING BEFORE THE HOUSE
FOREIGN AFFAIRS COMMITTEE,
POMPEO ADDRESSED HOW THE
VENEZUELAN GOVERNMENT NOTIFIED
THE STATE DEPARTMENT THAT IT'S
OBJECTING TO AMERICAN DIPLOMATS
IN RESPONSE TO U.S. SANCTIONS ON
VENEZUELA AFTER ITS PRESIDENT
NICOLAS MADURO WON REELECTION.
U.S. CONSIDERS THAT ELECTION A
SHAM.
ON RUSSIA, POMPEO COULD HAVE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AS
AGGRESSIVELY PUNISHES BEHAVIOR,
THOUGH ACKNOWLEDGES OFFICIALS
MUST DO MORE.
>> WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
ACHIEVE DETERRENCE, EFFECTIVE
DETERRENCE AND SOME OF THESE
EFFORTS OF THE RUSSIANS BUT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING
ENORMOUS EFFORTS TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST RUSSIA.
>> HE SAYS THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL IMPLEMENT APPROPRIATE
COUNTERMEASURES AGAINST RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE.
AFTER THE MORE THAN THREE HOUR
HEARING, POMPEO HOSTED OFFICIALS
FROM JAPAN, GERMANY AND CHINA.
POMPEO SAYS THE STATE DEPARTMENT
IS SENDING MEDICAL TEAM TO CHINA
AFTER A U.S. EMPLOYEE REPORTED
SYMPTOMS THAT ARE VERY SIMILAR
TO THOSE TWO DOZEN AMERICAN
DIPLOMATS IN CUBA EXPERIENCE.
>> WE HAVE NOTIFIED CHINA OF
WHAT TOOK PLACE.
THEY HAVE RESPONDED IN A WAY
THAT IS EXACTLY THE RIGHT
RESPONSE.
>> POMPEO DISCUSSED WITH CHINA'S
FOREIGN MINISTER THE UPCOMING
SUMMIT WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
KIM JONG UN.
HE SAYS OFFICIALS ARE STILL
PLANNING ON DRIVING FOR A
JUNE 12 MEETING.
HE ALSO NOTES THE UNITED STATES
WILL NOT GIVE ANY CONCESSIONS TO
NORTH KOREA UNTIL IT HAS
CREDIBLE INFORMATION,
DEMONSTRATION THAT IT'S
DISMANTLING ITS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
>> Bret: SPEAKING OF
CONCESSIONS, IRAN IS MAKING
DEMANDS OF EUROPE ON THE NUCLEAR
DEAL.
>> IT IS.
THEY EUROPEAN COUNTRIES AND
THOSE REMAINING IN THE IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL ARE NEGOTIATING
WITH IRAN, TRYING TO KEEP IT IN
THE IRAN NUCLEAR AGREEMENT OR
SALVAGE THE DEAL.
IRAN HAS POSTED A LIST OF
DEMANDS OF BRITAIN, GERMANY AND
FRANCE.
THE AYATOLLAH KHAMENEI WANTS
THEM TO GUARANTEE IRANIAN OIL
SALES, SAFEGUARD TRADING AND
SANCTIONS AND LEAVE ITS
BALLISTIC MISSILE PROGRAM AND
REGIONAL POLICIES ALONE.
THE AYATOLLAH SAYS THAT'S THE
PRICE FOR KEEPING IRAN AND THE
NUCLEAR DEAL.
IRAN IS PUTTING THE EUROPEANS
BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES AND
AROUND BECAUSE SECRETARY OF
STATE MIKE POMPEO ANNOUNCED
MONDAY 12 DEMANDS OF IRAN,
SAYING IT'S GOING TO PUT THE
STRONGEST SANCTIONS AND HISTORY
AGAINST IT IF IT DOESN'T COMPLY
WITH THE U.S. DEMANDS.